ist deutschland die heimstatt der
schnarchnasen und verschläft seine
zukunft zu wenig lang selbst denken zu
wenig digitalisierung die pannen in der
pandemie rund ums impfen testen kontakt
nachverfolgen bringen viele ins kugeln
musterknaben des fortschritts sind wir
offenbar nicht mehr deutschlands corona
management gut gemeint schlecht
organisiert jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet ist karin maag cdu
sie sind die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
teichert ist ebenfalls zugeschaltet die
vorsitzende des bundesverbandes der
ärztinnen und ärzte des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes als zum beispiel in
den gesundheitsämtern hier im studio zu
gast martin terhardt mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission abgekürzt stiko
dort werden die empfehlungen fürs impfen
natürlich auch gerade in der proa
pandemie gegeben
sie sind auch in fahrt und kinder und
jugendarzt und bei uns ist stefan ziller
bündnis 90 die grünen sind sprecher
ihrer fraktionen für digitales
verwaltungsmodernisierung und
armutsbekämpfung im abgeordnetenhaus
hier in berlin also im landesparlament
der bundeshauptstadt format er bevor er
zum thema kommen aus aktuellem anlass
weil das heute auch eine wichtige rolle
spielt die fraktionsspitze der union im
bundestag ralph brinkhaus alexander
dobrindt die wollen ein verhaltens
regime und anforderungen sind ihm für
abgeordnete erstellen da heißt es
wörtlich entgeltliche beratungs und
vermittlungstätigkeit die im direkten
zusammenhang mit dem aufgabengebiet der
fraktion stehen sind auszuschließen sie
sind gesundheitspolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion auf ihrer website
erwähnen sie ganz offen dass sie beirat
einer privaten krankenversicherung sind
und auch beraterin eines unternehmens
aus der medizinbranche was da jetzt
geplant wird wird die ja für sie
bedeuten wenn diese tätigkeiten was ich
an dem entgeltlich sind wie das ja in
diesem text auch heißen dass es sich aus
diesen beiden nebentätigkeiten
zurückziehen müssen
wenn denn das wahrscheinlich entstehen
ja werden sie das auch tun
verständlich also ich habe mich bisher
rechtskonform frage nicht alles
angemeldet ich habe transparenz
hergestellt
derzeit haben wir das ganze erwähnt und
falls wir jetzt fraktionsintern an
entsprechenden kodex uns geben dann hab
ich gießen zu beachten kein vertun
finden sie das richtig oder beugen sie
sich dem zwang der fraktionsführung
naja also im moment sieht es so aus dass
wenige unsere fraktion vielleicht auch
die ganze politik in verruf gebracht
haben
dann müssen wir jetzt erstmal gegen
arbeiten es gibt unendlich viele
abgeordnete auf bundes oder landesebene
lee verhalten sich gut und lediglich die
müssen sie schützen und beendest dazu
gehört das strenge verhaltens namen und
dann und das den schlimmsten und auch
den ansehen des parlaments dann ist es
vollkommen zum thema frau marx ist unser
politisches system sie beobachten ist ja
von der bundesebene aus
das besteht aus höchst unterschiedlichen
zuständigkeiten und eigene fähigkeiten
ist das im moment regelrecht überfordert
den anforderungen der korona pandemie
gerecht zu werden nein das ist nicht
immer ratsam vereinbart auf sicht zu
fahren wir alle egal
bundes- landes- oder kommunalebene sind
zum ersten mal mit einer familie in
diesem ausmaß in diesem ausmaß getroffen
und sich nicht vom regeln zu geben die
die erste inflationär verwendet wir
sehen uns gar nicht eigentlich dass es
[Musik]
aber ich sehe auch dass wirklich gute
fortschritte
wir haben die impfstoffe die ihm für
lieferungen werden besser wären
beispielsweise in den meisten ländern
die über 80-jährigen dem pflegeheim
wohnen geimpft es kommen jetzt die zahl
mit priorisierung gruppe daran haben die
tests gestellt ist und die eigentliche
eigentlich tatsächlich auch zum vertrieb
zugelassen worden
also ich sehe es uns in richtung sommer
auf einen möglichst guten weg befinden
wir müssen auf sicht fahren
vieles läuft nicht rund einiges läuft
was ist denn falsch gelaufen am karuna
management man hat ja wirklich den
eindruck das sagen auch umfragen nicht
nur unzufriedenheit mit dem lockdown
dass er noch länger dauert sondern auch
damit wie dieses management impfen
testen früher masken gelaufen ist da
gibt gerade so was an stimmung was läuft
da falsch
also ich glaube auf sicht fahren wenn
man sich zahlen anguckt und aktuelle
regelung macht sinn was man im
nachhinein sicherlich sagen muss dass
man im sommer letzten jahres und im
herbst nicht die nötigen vorkehrungen
gemacht hat und ich will das auch sagen
ich glaube das war ganz menschlich dass
wir alle die hoffnung haben dass es
nicht wieder so schlimm wird da haben zu
viele dran geglaubt und die nötigen
vorbereitungen für die zeit die wir
jetzt haben auch für den winter ob das
das digitale lernen ist oder auch das
regime dass wir jetzt in der app zum
beispiel schon hätten wo man testen
impfen und das alles nachweisen kann um
dann auch im alltag wieder zu gestalten
und das ordentlich vorzubereiten
das muss man uns allen vorwerfen aber
insgesamt bei den zahlen und maßnahmen
muss man natürlich auf sicht fahren bei
dir sozusagen nicht für monate raus
voraus geplant werden können und hat
wurde denn die öffentliche verwaltung
und da gehört ja auch die
gesundheitsverwaltung dazu aber
insgesamt die öffentliche verwaltung in
den letzten jahren kaputt gespart und
haben wir jetzt sozusagen die quittung
bekommen in der pandemie dass vieles
nicht unter kontrolle ist ja leider ist
genau das passiert man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen schon vor der panne
wurden die gesundheitsämter ist
statische runter gespart personal
eingespart es wurde alles gekürzt wir
haben in japan jetzt gesehen dass das
ein fehler war es ist wie mit dem rennen
hast uns vor augen dass wir dringend da
nachrüsten müssen aber auch da passiert
bisher nicht wirklich was wir haben
einzelne verbesserungen wir haben aber
bisher keine systemverbesserungen und
das wäre dringend notwendig der ta hat
liegt es eigentlich nur am
impfstoffmangel dass die die
zufriedenheit die unzufriedenheit in
deutschland mit dem impfen im moment so
groß ist
ich denke daran liegt dass hauptsächlich
wir haben ja eine entwicklung bei den
impfstoff lieferungen am anfang lief es
ja wirklich ganz ganz schleppen und
jetzt kommt nach und nach mehr
impfstoffe und das wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich explosionsartig mehr
impfstoff in den nächsten wochen und
monaten kommen aber generell ist das
system das wir jetzt in deutschland
aufgebaut haben ja völlig neu
also impfzentren und mobile dienste gab
es bisher nie das müssen wir alle zum
ersten mal machen und das hat glaube ich
viele systeme in unserem föderalen land
überfordert aber woran lag das letztes
jahr waren wir ja für viele europäische
nachbarn überhaupt eigentlich global ein
vorbild wie wir da im märz/april krisen
management betrieben haben und jetzt
sind wir das sorgenkind der pandemie
bekämpfung wie ist es so weit gekommen
also ich denke das sorgenkind sind wir
vielleicht in der fall sterblichkeit
zurzeit unter der anzahl an todesfällen
den pflegeheimen und vielleicht auch in
der schnelligkeit beim impfen aber das
muss man glaube ich sehr deutlich
trennen die schnelligkeit bei wimpfen
liegt hauptsächlich an der impfstoff
lieferung und da sind für vergleichbar
mit den anderen europäischen ländern
außer großbritannien und was die fälle
in den pflegeheimen geht das muss
sicherlich noch mal aufgearbeitet werden
wie wir da in den hygiene plänen und in
der um im umgang mit dem problem besser
werden können so mag der frau teichert
hat ja gerade aufgezählt wo es hakt
jetzt aus ihrem bereich
das fällt ja sowieso auf das wir haben
defizite auf vielen ebenen im bereich
der technischen ausstattung der so
genannten workflows wie man vorgeht und
so weiter aber man hat auch mehr so das
gefühl keiner fühlt sich so richtig
zuständig haben wir eine organisierte
verantwortungslosigkeit in dieser frage
das nicht obwohl er nicht zuständig ist
zum beispiel für einige sind schon sehr
zuständig gefühlt im herbst letzten
jahres und hat im investiven bereich 3
milliarden euro zur verfügung gestellt
zur besseren ausstattung bild
gesundheitsämter die länder zu werten zu
nehmen
die ist ein paar mal gehört haben sich
gemacht bezahlen zu verbessern also man
sieht schon dass etwas getan wird in die
ablöse für den freitag bereichern ist
richtig wir haben erst in der krise
gemerkt was wir an unseren
gesundheitsämtern öffentlich müssen als
sie und deswegen ist es jetzt formal
beiden ländern zuständig dass wir da
verbesserungen und zwar sehr schnell
einführen müssen frage was sagen warum
ist in der zweiten welle schlechten aus
meiner sicht aber zu spät
das war und haben wahrscheinlich im
sommer auch viele gelegenheiten
verschlagen vorteil hat nochmal zu den
öffentlichen gesundheits zu den
gesundheitsämtern wofür sie ja zuständig
sind wo sie als ärztin auch arbeiten was
fehlt da konkret oder was ist sozusagen
vorsintflutlich sind es nur die
faxgeräte die sprichwörtlichen die
überall noch rum stehen um zu
kommunizieren oder gibt es generell da
ein strukturproblem
also ich musste gerade lachen als sie
nach der verantwortungslosigkeit
gefragter verantwortlichkeit die fehlt
da ist tatsächlich was dran wenn man das
auch so nicht genau sagen kann weil es
ist klar gesetzlich geregelt wer
zuständig ist nämlich die länder
es gibt länder gesetze über den
öffentliche gesundheitsdienstleister
wieder klar geregelt wie das in den
einzelnen bundesländern läuft wir haben
aber im bund keine zuständigkeit keine
originäre zuständigkeit für den bereich
und ansonsten hängen die gesundheitsamt
an
kommunen und an den städten so dass da
auch die zuständigkeiten sind dh wir
haben im grunde gar ganz viele
zuständige und das ist so das problem
einer schiebt hinter dem anderen her
oder vor dem andern er und das schließt
jetzt anderen die frage die sie gerade
gestellt haben ich würde auch gerne
aufräumen mit dem fax märchen natürlich
ist es so dass auch faxe noch in
gesundheitsämtern stehen und auch noch
bedient werden das liegt aber nicht
daran dass die gesundheitsamt so
rückständig sind die sind
zwischenzeitlich eigentlich durchweg
fast alle digitalisiert aber es liegt
natürlich auch daran dass die
gesundheitsamt sei ja auch empfangen
müssen die behörden brings rum die
arztpraxen kitas schulen usw
alle müssen melden und die haben nicht
alle ein digitales system mit dem sie
melden können und da ist das fax immer
noch das zuverlässigste mittel und
deswegen stehen auch noch die faxe gut
jetzt haben sie vorher gesagt im film
was das gesundheitswesen angeht sind die
länder zuständig hat sich das sich ja
außerordentlich günstig dass wir ein
vertreter eines landesparlaments wir
haben mit herrn sieger nämlich das
abgeordnetenhaus in berlin dass er das
bundesland repräsentiert sind die länder
zu wenig bekommen sie zu wenig ihrer
aufgabe nach muss dazu sagen ihre partei
ist ja an der berliner landesregierung
geben dass senat beteiligten berlin gibt
es einen schönen begriff behörden ping
pong keiner ist zuständig für so lange
hin und hergeschoben ist gar nicht mehr
weiß um was es geht liegt da ein großes
problem nicht nur in berlin
also ich glaube was die gesundheitsämter
angeht gibt es zwei baustellen also das
eine ist die verwaltung wir haben in
berlin muss der gesundheitsamt was die
personalausstattung angeht
und das zweite ist die frage von
digitalisierung und da glaube ich ist
der punkt zuständigkeit und übernahme
von verantwortung einer der uns in der
panini vorgeführt wurde dass der nicht
so gut läuft wir haben in berlin das e
government gesetz das regelt das sehr
klar die senatsverwaltung für gesundheit
pflege und gleichstellung ist für die
ausstattung und die fachverfahren in den
gesundheitsämtern zuständig das macht
auch sinn dass das einmal entschieden
wird und dann nicht jedes gesundheits
oder andere vater denkt diese
verantwortung ist wir haben das in
berlin
ein unkontrollierter die exekutiven und
habe schaue auf die finger und die frage
wie gut ist die verwaltung sie haben
jetzt den fall bei
da kann man auch andere bundesländer
nehmen nehmen wir berlin wie gut ist die
verwaltung für solche krisen aufgestellt
die jede verwaltung auf dem falschen fuß
erwischt kein mensch kann das
voraussehen
berlin war vor der krise nicht gut
aufgestellt was digitalisierung angeht
die hausaufgaben wurden nicht gemacht
wir haben eine technik zu auch gerade in
den bezirken das ist ein problem was in
der krise aufzuarbeiten eine große
herausforderung ist insofern da gab es
da die fehlende das war nicht einfach
nicht ein trainiert dass die
senatsverwaltung auch klar am anfang der
krise sagt sodass es dass die software
das und das muss im zweifel noch gemacht
werden damit das in den bezirken dafür
werde das gesetz an der stelle anpassen
und noch mal klarstellen dass er auch
sich niemand mehr aus der verantwortung
ziehen kann und wir haben das bundesweit
ja die diskussion nicht jedes
gesundheitsamt nicht jede kommune muss
das neu erfinden wir brauchen da die
gremien wie it planungsrat oder auf
länderebene unseren ik t lenkungsrat und
die müssen funktionieren und das
organisieren das dann auch in die
kommunen handlungs sicher agieren können
der hat was wir jetzt an defiziten schon
erwähnt haben wie wirkt das zum beispiel
aufs management zurück also ich denke
das management ist auch ein problem im
föderalismus wir haben halt die
niedergelassenen ärzte die hauptsächlich
fürs impfen zuständig sind wir haben die
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste die bei
der einschulungsuntersuchung war den
kindern die impfquoten prüfen
ansonsten haben wir kein gutes system
die impfquoten wirklich regelmäßig
standardisiert zu überprüfen außer über
kv also abrechnungsdaten von kassen
ärzten das kommt auch sehr spät und das
hauptproblem sehe ich darin dass die
daten die wir dann erheben eigentlich in
deutschland nur sehr selten dazu führen
dass wirklich kleinteilig regional dann
die richtigen konsequenzen gezogen
werden
wir erheben daten für die ganze
bundesrepublik für die ganzen einzelnen
bundesländern sogar für einzelne
gemeinden sogar in den einzelnen
gemeinden ganz kleinteilig und da
müssten wir dann kleinteilig
konsequenzen ziehen wenn wir sehen die
impfquoten dann schlecht und da sind wir
noch nicht gut genug auch jetzt in der
pandemie finde ich ein gutes beispiel
wir heben jetzt tagesaktuell das haben
wir noch nie in deutschland hingekriegt
impfquoten in ganz deutschland wir
können tagesaktuell sagen wieviel 80plus
jährige sind schon geimpft und da wo die
noch nicht gut gekämpft sind da durfte
man jetzt nicht die priorisierung öffnen
dann müsste man sich darum kümmern dass
die 80plus ihren geimpft werden und das
mangelt mir in dieser weise
ja immer wieder gerade diese 80plus die
hochbetagten die einwohner von oder
bewohner von pflegeheimen die sind ja
schon weitgehend durchgeimpft da singt
die todeszahl das sind auch die so
genannte incidents gewaltig das heißt
eigentlich haben sie ja den ersten teil
des auftrags schon erfüllt dass ein
großteil dieser betagten hochbetagten
risikogruppen geimpft ist da man sich
ein bisschen wasser in den wein schütten
also bei den pflegeheimen stimmt das was
sie sagen da sind die zahlen bundesweit
was die im quoten angeht wirklich sehr
gut aber da ist das setting auch ganz
einfach zu erreichen das ist das
pflegeheim da fährt man hin da wird
geimpft das sind alle auf einmal da aber
die anderen menschen die 80 plus sind
und zu hause leben die müssen in das
impfzentrum gehen müssen wir ein taxi da
hinfahren oder wenn sie das nicht können
müssen sie auch besucht werden und da
sind wir in deutschland bisher noch
nicht gut genug das ist auch in jedem
bundesland anders aber diese
personengruppe die dürft darf man jetzt
nicht vergessen das ist mir eine große
verbände der vorwurf dass wir zwar im
moment einen impfstoffmangel haben aber
man könnte trotzdem noch mehr impfen das
ist einfach auch an den kapazitäten auch
am verimpft management täglich liegt ja
da ist sicherlich auch was dran das wird
jetzt aber jeden tag besser weil die
impfzentren ja jetzt auch erfahrungen
gesammelt haben und jetzt nach und nach
auch ihre kapazitäten ausweiten können
weil sie das vorher trainiert haben ich
denke das wird jetzt besser
ich weiß dass hier aus berlin dass das
wirklich jetzt massiv aufgestockt wird
ich denke das wird mit der zeit besser
aber am anfang lag es einfach an der
lieferung des impfstoffs das ist halt
auch nicht schneller sein konnte an der
körpersprache von format und friedrich
hat sich das etwas dazu sagen wollen vom
markt mittel landes im zentrum da ist es
natürlich so die kapazitäten wären da
die nächsten beiden wochen dass das war
ja dankbar
das team hat auch gesagt hat das ist
jetzt mit der lieferung explodiert und
anfang april noch die niedergelassenen
er jetzt in die betriebs ist einschalten
können die rechtsgrundlage die
mittlerweile vor
dann müsste es wirklich ein extremes
entgegen aber tatsache ist das könnte
noch besser werden
ich halte das für ein ganz wichtigen
punkt was hat er hat eben gesagt hat wir
erheben tagesaktuell die daten wir
können sofort sehen wo was verimpft wird
und wir müssen da jetzt direkt darauf
reagieren kann
ich war auch im impfzentrum gestern dort
wo der astra zenica fünft und da war ein
anderes problem die leute sind nicht
gekommen
also impfstoff war da es waren genügend
da die geimpft hatten aber die
vereinbarten termine wurden nicht
abgesagt oder die leute sind nicht
gekommen und das höre ich eben aus
anderen zusammenhängen auch dass diese
koppelung diese organisatorische
koppelung die da ist an die impftermine
das ist ein sehr starres system und wenn
wir doch sehen dass die menschen das
nicht annehmen und können das
tagesaktuelle erheben dann müssten wir
direkt darin gehen und die organisation
verändern das fände ich wäre ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt das könnten wir
auch regional genau dort machen wo wir
sehen dass dort weniger geimpft wird
hertha hat hat es ja auch gerade gesagt
bei den mobilen im teams haben wir gute
erfahrungen gemacht
warum nutzen wir nicht die erfahrung wir
wissen wir erwischen die leute am besten
in ihrer umgebung in ihrem setting wie
wir so schön sagen warum impfen will
nicht großflächig in betrieben in alten
pflegeheimen krankenhäusern der läuft es
ja jetzt in den kitas in den schulen wir
haben aber jetzt das system das alle ins
zentrum kommen müssen und dann stehen
die leute sich die beiden den bauch weil
keiner kommt und ist es genug impfstoff
da
da müsste man glaube ich auch ein
satirisch noch einmal sehr genau
hingucken
ich würde gerne das thema einsteigen
die sich jede einzelne gewusst haben
zwar nicht ausdrücklich nachgefragt also
da möchte ich jetzt schon nicht alles
über einen kamm
wir kommen auf das thema impfen gleich
nochmal im anderen zusammenhang zurück
der auch die einzelnen bundesländern
sehr wichtig ist wir werden das thema
immer gleich nochmal ansprechen
vielleicht noch mal etwas ganz generell
die frage wie sind wir aufgestellt wie
professionell arbeitet die verwaltung
nicht in der gesundheitsverwaltung das
sind viele verwaltungs überhaupt die
ganze öffentliche verwaltung in der ein
oder anderen weise beteiligt auf der
kommunalen auf der länder auch auf der
bundesebene
und da gibt es eine menge defizite
ausstattung personalkapazität vielleicht
auch motivation der mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter auch die vernetzung
untereinander analog wie digital meine
ich dass jetzt sie haben die gnade der
späten geburt der jüngste hier aber
haben uns die letzten jahrzehnte dieses
guten leben schon der gute zeit in jeder
verbracht haben auch immer besonders gut
angesehen zu werden immer sehr
fortschrittlich zu sein haben uns die zu
selbstzufrieden zu träge gemacht also
dass unsere politischen oder
verwaltungsinternen prozesse zu träge
sind würde glaube ich jeder
unterschreiben wir haben ein problem
sein ich glaube es liegt nicht an der
motivation der mitarbeiterinnen da ist
ganz deutlich also das was ich in berlin
lebe ist dass die mitarbeiterin auch
wollen ich glaube es braucht eine
führungskultur die auch entscheidet und
sachen ermöglicht und auch in der krise
mal sagt wir gehen jetzt den weg auch
wenn wir noch nicht alle sackgassen und
gassen vor uns angeguckt haben das ist
sicherlich ein entscheidungs defizit was
wir haben aber wir hatten gerade in
berlin nach den spar jahren große
probleme wir sind gerade dabei die
verwaltung wieder aufzubauen in allen
bereichen in bezirken aber auch
senatsverwaltung und da kamen die krise
zu früh dass das funktioniert hat
insofern wir werden das weiter machen
ich glaube aber auch wenn ich mir das
angucken was in der verwaltung auch an
digitalisierung an prozessoptimierung
gemacht wird dass wir in den nächsten
jahren da viele viele fortschritte sehen
werden und das sozusagen im
maschinenraum schon sehr viel
vorbereitet wird was dann funktioniert
zb digitale antrag der war so
vorbereitet dass der quasi in einer
krise genau geholfen hat und dann für
diverse sachen nutzbar war
also da ist einiges auf dem weg aber
insgesamt sind die prozesse zu träge
aber ihr vorhin gesagt in der krise
haben wir uns jetzt bisher ganz gut
behauptet aus ihrer sicht zumindest aber
vorher waren wir schlecht ausgestellt
gewesen das heißt dieses defizit hat er
mit corona zunächst mal nicht ursächlich
zu tun sondern ist durch corona januar
verstärkt worden
das heißt wir sind tatsächlich was
dieses also verwaltungsmanagement
bürokratie auch eine effiziente
effizientes regieren effizientes
verwalten nicht gut aufgestellt
nein und das dass wir als die
politischen entscheidungsträger an
manchen stellen auch nicht gelernt haben
mutig zu entscheiden oder sozusagen
offensiv zu entscheiden ist etwas was
uns in der krise nicht geholfen hat also
wenn berlin bis heute nicht in der lage
ist für alle verwaltungseinheiten
videokonferenz- tool zur verfügung zu
stellen das funktioniert das ist ein
entscheidungs defizit technisch ist das
überhaupt kein problem
und man kann auch mit
datenschutzbeauftragten sprechen das ist
es ein entscheidungs defizit auf der
anderen seite hat berlin für alle
schulen schnelltest gekauft bevor die
zugelassen waren da wurde mutig
entschieden weil wir wissen dass wir in
schulen test müssen also es gibt beides
und wir müssen einfach lernen da ein
gesundes maß zu finden an den ständen
nötiges zu entscheiden und dann auf die
politische verantwortung dafür zu
übernehmen haben dir herr t hat ein
problem auch in unserem land damit dass
wir vieles zu sehr verrechtlicht haben
dass wir das ist zuviel
rechtsvorschriften geht dass wir uns in
einem riesigen paragrafendschungel
verheddern was ich jetzt auch eben uns
wieder vor die füße fällt
bei der krone pandemie das gilt aber
auch für andere zusammenhänge für andere
bereiche des lebens das wir uns
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig
bewegen können in all diesen regeln und
regularien von denen ein teil völlig
überflüssig ist würde ich ihn
uneingeschränkt zustimmen und ich denke
das machen uns andere länder auch vor
dass man einfach mal nur machen muss und
nicht so viel paragrafen welt und auch
der datenschutz ist da sicherlich ein
thema wo wir es etwas übertrieben haben
bisher und wo uns das jetzt ein bisschen
auf die füße fällt auch wenn wir da
vorsichtig sein müssen und ich denke
generell dass die korona pandemie ganz
viele schwachstellen in unserer
gesellschaft aufzeigt gerade
gesundheitssystem bildungssystemen
brauchen wir glaube ich keinen der das
nicht so sieht und ich denke dass da
auch der föderalismus noch ein bisschen
dazu lernen muss und beim impfen
ist es auch sichtbar wenn sie sich in
seinem zentrum reingehen die
aufklärungsbogen müssen alle
unterschrieben wenn dann müssen sie
eingescannt werden wenn sie beim arzt
geimpft werden wollen müssen sie jedes
mal was unterschreiben
eigentlich nicht unbedingt ist das auch
nicht vorgeschrieben aber wir regeln das
jetzt so dass die patienten die
aufklärung im impfzentrum bekommen durch
lesen müssen unterschreiben müssen
nochmal die einwilligung unterschreiben
müssen dann muss der arzt das noch
unterschreiben dann muss das eingescannt
werden dann muss das als lka geschickt
werden und dann wird dem markt da gibt
es ja gerade auf bundesebene eine ganze
reihe von kommission das geht jahre
zurück die sich mit bürokratieabbau
beschäftigen
diesen rechts schummel diesen rechte
dschungel zu entwirren zu lichten
irgendwie das gefühl jedes mal wenn sich
so eine kommission diesem thema
beschäftigt ist es danach bestenfalls
verschlimmbessert oder doch schlimmer
ist da einfach noch zu wenig passiert
auch von politischer seite diese die
sind recht dieses rechte wirrwarr das
uns jetzt aber auch irgendwie in der
korona pandemie so das leben schwer
macht das dazu wenig passiert ist um das
zu entwirren
es gibt beispielsweise in einen
normenkontrollrat der gute ergebnisse
erzielt natürlich jetzt nicht zwingend
in die ihn erreichen die jetzt in
erkannten die relevant sind
ich will natürlich immer noch der mut so
etwas umzusetzen
ja natürlich das auf unterschiedlichsten
ebenen täglich viel abgestimmt werden
muss sie lag ganz klar gesagt
vereinbarte muss übergangen werden ich
sehe dort wo einzelne versuchen
vereinbaren übernehmen nämlich auf
kommunaler ebene auf landkreisebene in
zu ihren bereich das sind verliert das
ich komme aus baden württemberger maße
die ganz selbstständig auf die idee
kommen zu testen
die strahlend ist ein beispiel dafür wie
beispielsweise ich sie aufnehmen
das ist in menschen die verantwortung
übernehmen und wie dann auch
offensichtlich so gestellt sind dass sie
sagen es mag sein dass am ende irgendwo
auch was schief läuft aber ich stelle
mich dann meinen gemeinderat meiner
chrysler meinen bürgern und ich hab's
dann wenigstens gemacht und das ist
etwas was wir lernen müssen davon wie
zutiefst überzeugt mit brauchen menschen
die verantwortung übernehmen wir müssen
natürlich auch die frage beantworten
müssen die lessons learned die
nahost-krise dann ziehen wir auch als
bundestag jetzt schon die evaluation in
allen bereichen in auftrag gegeben
aber das ging wie wichtig sind wir haben
den datenschutz auch da bin ich wirklich
mit dem herd vollkommen einig
datenschutz ist wichtig insbesondere
auch für unsere bürger mit einer
unterschiedlichen vergangenheit zwar
drittes reich und und die ddr
aber der datenschutz darf nicht als
entschuldigung dienen und letzte
dokumentation das ist nicht erst seit
der familie durch diese dokumentation
wird kein patient ist gut wir müssen
tatsächlich besser werden und das ist
die aufgabe eines normenkontrollrates
ist aufgabe der länder ebene von
entsprechenden retten und es wird ganz
ganz sicher etwas sein was wir
untersuchen müssen nach der krise und da
setze ich mich auch gern dafür ein das
schlanker werden
gut das steht auch auf der to do liste
der sendung noch das thema datenschutz
vorteil hat was frau mag gerade
skizziert hat zum beispiel böblingen
tübingen
das wird aber die leuchttürme die in der
landschaft einfach stehen wo das
funktioniert eine kollegin von ihnen in
tübingen hat sich das hat sich der sache
angenommen
aber es gibt eigentlich ja viel zu wenig
leuchttürme die leuchten zwar ein
bisschen aber die dunkelheit drumherum
bleibt ist da einfach jetzt auch was
ihren bereich angeht bisher viel zu
wenig passiert und wie kann man diese
defizite möglichst schnell überbrückt
man das gefühl ist eine riesenaufgabe
die möglicherweise jahre dauert bis wir
auf einem stand sind mit dem wir dann
zufrieden sind wo wir sagen wir haben
gesundheitsverwaltung wir haben krisen
management im griff also mit dem
leuchtturm haben sie recht
ich finde das wirklich auch weil ich
gerade baden württemberg ist da ganz
besonders für da führend und macht sehr
gute geschichten auch was da in tübingen
und böblingen passiert wird ja gerade
sehr aktuell berichtet aber ich finde es
gut und mutig dass es menschen gibt die
sowas machen
ich glaube dass wir das in der krise
unbedingt brauchen
aber wir können nicht nur auf solche
menschen bauen sondern wir müssen
eigentlich unser system in dem fall auch
noch mal angucken
gerade das thema datenschutz wir haben
ist jetzt gerade gehört wie wichtig das
ist ich kann das nachvollziehen aber ich
bin ärztin komme aus dem bereich
öffentliche gesundheit ganz hohes gut
und als ganz hohes gut und wenn ich eine
pandemie bekämpfen will und datenschutz
steht über gesundheitsschutz
dann habe ich damit ein problem und
denke das führt uns in der pandemie
nicht weiter da müssten wir auch in der
lage sein flexibel zu reagieren
wir reden darüber dass das kontaktperson
management gemacht werden soll dass es
nicht digitalisiert ist und gleichzeitig
werden aber aus datenschutzgründen wird
es verwehrt dass daten die in einer app
gesammelt werden an die gesundheitsämter
weitergeleitet werden und dann wundere
ich mich warum die gesundheitsämter so
langsam sind und weil das ganze system
so lange braucht das geht so aus meiner
sicht nicht mehr und da müssen wir auch
jetzt akut ran und können nicht sagen
auch privat mal lasst uns lernt eines
tages haben wir zeit da können wir uns
wieder um alles kümmern
dann machen die strukturprobleme und
gesetzliche regelungen datenschutz und
so weiter nein wir sind jetzt in der
krise wir sind jetzt in der pandemie und
sie ist noch nicht zu ende
ganz im gegenteil wir müssen ja jetzt
ran bei der form des datenschutzes das
schild bei den grünen normalerweise die
alarmglocken
sie haben ja dass sich auch auf ihre
fahnen geschrieben da besonders den
behörden überhaupt allen die macht haben
auf die finger zu sehen aber wird das
jetzt nicht tatsächlich übertrieben muss
das im fall des pandemie schutzes nicht
neu justiert werden dass man also daten
schneller an die gesundheitsämter
übermitteln kann
kontakt nachverfolgung das einfach die
bekämpfung der pandemie gerade mit
diesen digitalen strukturen die sie ja
auch fordern dass das einfach dass der
datenschutz da ein stück weit
zurückstehen muss wir haben ja beispiele
aus israel aus taiwan und südkorea da
sind auch demokratische staaten wo das
sehr viel rigoroser ist mit dem ergebnis
dass dort das öffentliche leben also
zumindest in südkorea taiwan ziemlich
normal läuft haben wir zu sehr auf
datenschutz und zu wenig auf gesundheit
oder achten wir zu wenig auf den auf den
gesundheitsschutz und zu sehr auf den
datenschutz
ich halte die ausrede datenschutz
tatsächlich für sozusagen nicht ziel
führen weil ich glaube die probleme dass
die schnittstellen zu den
gesundheitsämtern nicht funktionieren
liegt nicht am datenschutz und im
gegenteil deutschland oder auch die
europäische union hat mit der mit der
korona war angefangen
das hat nicht funktioniert aber das hat
irgendwann dann aufgehört das so zu
entwickeln wie es nötig ist es gab immer
wieder vorschläge wie man genau diese
schnittstellen die jetzt auch wieder in
der diskussion sind die kriegt man da
rein dass ich meinen test irgendwie
dokumentieren kann also wir haben in
deutschland so viele tolle menschen die
auch datenschutzkonforme sozusagen
nachvollziehbarkeit herstellen dazu
diese digitalen tools nutzen ich finde
wir haben daraus aus dem potenzial was
wir haben zu wenig gemacht und ich habe
tatsächlich dann sorge als grüner aber
auch als datenschützer dass ich nicht
will dass wir so eine infrastruktur
aufbauen
die tatsächlich dann zuviel
nachvollziehbar macht oder zu gläsern
ist also ich glaube die ziele sind
vereinbar
und die ausrede datenschutz dafür dass
die gesundheitsämter keine schnittstelle
haben es mir zu billig aber ist nicht
dass ihr wirklich das problem dass hier
zu wenig schnittstellen haben dass die
datennetze der einzelnen ebenen gehörten
zuständigen nicht vernetzt sind dass das
nicht funktioniert sie nochmal sie
kritisieren ja das
das digitale im argen liegt aber dass
wir genau da ja eigentlich einen
besseren transfer brauchen eine bessere
struktur und die erfordert eben
möglicherweise auch einen neuen blick
auf den datenschutz damit dass alles
funktioniert wie es geht ja um die
bekämpfung einer für manche tödlichen
krankheit
ja aber bei daten geht es darum auch
selbstbestimmt mit seinen daten
umzugehen und natürlich vielen
schnittstellen und wenn ich möchte dass
meine daten bei gesundheitsamt und bei
den anderen ämtern zur verfügung stehen
und ich mich jedes mal alles neu aus
vollmerz dass meine entscheidung und die
tools müssen das ermöglichen dass das
funktioniert und die kontakt nach
verfolgung über diese app die anonym
funktioniert gibt es ja und das weiter
zu entwickeln das auch für cafés oder
für alles an sozialem leben was wir
brauchen
das liegt auf dem tisch da kann man auch
viel mehr machen als die app bis heute
bietet und da hilft uns die diskussion
über sozusagen irgendeine datenschutz
regeln die wir jetzt ändern müssen und
dann wäre alles gut ist so einfach
was muss man beim datenschutz passieren
sie haben ja gerade schon angedeutet
sind brauchen ja auch politische
mehrheiten das muss sich auch in den
länderparlamenten gemacht wenn der ärger
die länder auch ein gehöriges wort
mitzureden
der bundesrat auch noch wenn man dann
also die ganzen kämen jetzt auf sie
aufzählt die da beteiligt sind dann weiß
man ja dass das keine schnelle
angelegenheit verändert
der boden ist ich nicht falsch verstehen
ich will hier nicht irgendwelche da den
datenschutz abschaffen
ganz sicher nicht dass das während des
verbs man kann jetzt besonders
überziehen und ich will das festmachen
beispielsweise eine bank das thema am
anfang wir haben endlich das ist dass
jene datenschützern im land damit
einverstanden
tatsächlich erreicht das vorab geklärt
war dass die daten gesammelt werden
können nirgendwo auf einen server
abgelegt werden können und jetzt
in der not in der krise denn es regnet
dann müssen wir uns gleichzeitig
vorwerfen vorwerfen lassen dass genau
dies nicht möglich ist in dieser
ausnahmesituation und wir sprechen von
einem bewohner waren es 25 millionen
deutsche freiwillig wunder geladen
freiwillig keine gezwungen und in diesem
in diesem bereich denn wenn ich da rein
in ihr könnten besser werden dann dann
wir könnten uns absprechen mit
denjenigen beispielsweise jetzt mit
ihnen herum sagen in diesen in diesem
engen wirklich wichtigen phase muss es
möglich sein dass dass wir besser werden
dann dachte ich das kann kein falsches
an sinn und ich mir beispielsweise auch
das thema forschungsdaten nehmen bis ein
durchaus mit einem anderen
gesundheitssystem die daten seiner
seiner neu dazu verfügung gestellt ach
auswies jetzt war ich jetzt weiß auch in
deutschland bestehen stoff durchaus auch
wirksam ist für die über 65 jährigen das
ist eine sehr gute langsamkeit hat also
anders massenimpfung richten haben war
es spricht vieles dafür dass das zu
recht
also ich finde da hat er diese beispiele
der messungen des der impfstoff
wirksamkeit aus israel und aus
großbritannien zeigen dass das bei uns
in deutschland so nie funktioniert hätte
so ein nachweis wir hätten diese daten
in der schnelligkeit überhaupt nicht
miteinander verbinden können erkrankung
von patienten 119 und ihre impfstatus
das können die engländer weise ein
nationales gesundheitssystem hat mit
einer daten verknüpfung die jederzeit
möglichkeit das können die israelischen
einzelnen karten
da gibt es nur 9 die das halt auch in
ihren patienten gruppen dann sofort
zuordnen können wir haben in deutschland
so viele krankenkassen durch diese
praxis verwaltungssysteme das könnten
wir überhaupt nicht das kann auch das
robert-koch-institut nur mit sehr großem
zeitlichen verzögerungen oder die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung und da
werden halt patientendaten die wir alle
erheben nicht verknüpft wahr gemacht und
das ist ein problem das mit datenschutz
zusammenhängt und das problem könnten
wir ganz einfach lösen also das glaube
ich nicht
ich glaube auch der dann gesagt der
datenschutz ist die falsche ausrede also
zum einen die korona wahrnimmt hat jetzt
die daten spende
da hätte man von anfang an darauf arbeit
freiwillig ja aber es haben sich wie 25
millionen dieser app heruntergeladen und
und ich behaupte mal als wir werden ja
sehen wie die kampagne läuft hätte man
das am anfang auch so kommuniziert das
was freiwillig funktioniert hätten wir
in deutschland vielleicht auch mehr
daten erfassen können oder auch den
gesundheitsämtern mehr analysen zur
verfügung stellen können ist es eine
stärke dass wir das auch sozial in
deutschland konzipieren diese systeme
die im daten sparsam sind und ich glaube
auch das problem sind eher die software
die die krankenkassen und systeme haben
als der sozen datenschutz
das ist in deutschland geht es ja dass
man freiwillig auch entscheidet was mit
seinen daten passiert solange das system
in was genutzt wird das aber nicht
ermöglicht dass ich sage ich will gerne
dass das ärger in meinem status was man
haben kann
das ist das problem also nicht die
aufhebung von datenschutz sondern die
systeme müssen da einfach bessere
schnittstellen haben und einfach auch
den zweck erfüllen das heißt dann wieder
die durchdringung von rechte von
verwaltungs- von behördendschungel das
haben sie ja gerade angesprochen ich
würde gerne auf ein anderes thema kurz
kommen die waren schon mal beim instant
gerade gewesen
johnson & johnson wird jetzt in den
nächsten tagen wahrscheinlich in der eu
zugelassen der impfstoff hat einen
vorteil man muss sie nur einmal für
impfen aber heute kam gleich die
hiobsbotschaft hinterher möglicherweise
sagt johnson & johnson können diese 55
millionen dosen die im zweiten quartal
geliefert werden sollen gar nicht
geliefert werden
rohstoff nachlieferung für die
impfstoffe hakt und und funktioniert
nicht richtig gleichzeitig die
produktionsstrukturen leben wir jetzt
nochmal das gleiche debakel
das kann ich jetzt zum diesem zeitpunkt
noch nicht richtig gut beurteilen das
war vor
schon klar dass dieser impfstoff vor
april nicht zu erwarten ist das heißt
wenn er jetzt zugelassen wird heißt das
für deutschland nicht sofort dass wir
ihn auch haben ob wir denn jetzt
wirklich im april bekommen oder erst
später kann ich aus meiner position
nicht beurteilen aber ich denke das
zeigt auch wieder dass wir besser
wahrscheinlich vor vielen monaten sechs
sieben acht monaten in
produktionskapazitäten und in refrath
kapazitäten für zusatzstoffe hätten
investieren sollen und weniger in die
forschung entwicklung das natürlich auch
aber nicht einfach so sagen wir kaufen
jetzt impfstoff ein sondern wir kaufen
uns produktionskapazität chancen und
schon sehr gesagt sie wollen dass
trotzdem noch möglich machen wir mal
anders geht gut aus dann kommt ein
unglaublicher schwung an impfstoffen zu
uns dann haben wir möglicherweise das
nächste problem nämlich ins kapazitäten
wir haben die impfzentren jetzt sollen
auch die hausärzte ran ich habe so ein
bisschen das gefühl gehabt dass die
ständige impfkommission das nicht
sozusagen etwas skeptisch sieht dass es
jetzt auch auf haus und später auch
betriebsärzte also niedergelassene
ärztin betriebsärzte übergeht haben sie
da noch bedenken aber bezug was die
priorisierung dann angeht in den
arztpraxen auf die priorisierung habe
ich teilweise schon auch noch bedenken
weil wir das bei den influenza impfungen
sehen dass nicht nur die priorisierten
gruppen geimpft werden sondern auch alle
anderen oft geimpft werden und wird
damit den impfquoten in deutschland noch
nicht gut genug sind weder bei den über
60-jährigen wo es noch ganz gut geht
aber bei den chronisch kranken sind wir
dann nicht gut und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass in hausarztpraxen auch
viele patienten manchmal vergessen
werden die chronisch krank sind zum
patienten gut gehören aber nicht
regelmäßig anwesend sind und ich denke
das ist nicht die alleinige lösung wir
brauchen beides die institute ist die
frage gewesen das eine tun ohne das
andere zu lassen also heißt aber auf
jeden fall mit den hausarztpraxen gibt
es ja immerhin 75.000 im land und dann
wird ja olaf scholz hat ja schon
angekündigt zehn millionen impfdosen im
monat als gesamt könnte er das erwartet
er jetzt in den nächsten monaten mit
versprechungen sollte man immer etwas
vorsichtig sein aber generell haben sie
mit dem haus praxen da kein problem wenn
das auch
also es gibt auch andere praktische
probleme also die wartezeit nach der
impfung von 15 minuten ist ein
organisatorisches problem
die verarbeitung des impfstoffes wo
immer nur zehn dosen in einem fläschchen
drin sind dass man halt auch immer zehn
patienten anwesend haben muss an dieser
sprechstunde
das sind schon noch probleme die in der
praxis etwas schlechter gelöst werden
können als im impfzentrum die können
dort gelöst werden aber erfordern
organisatorischen aufwand weichert ja
ich halte es für ganz dringend noch mal
darauf hinzuweisen dass ich glaube alle
die impfen können sollen auch empfohlen
und da gehören die abstrakten dazu da
gehören die impfzentren
selbstverständlich dazu aber auch die
betriebe die betriebsärzte da ist eine
ganz breite struktur vom impfen und auch
gesundheitsämter natürlich kann auch
gesundheitsämter impfen
und ich meine wir müssen impfen so
schnell wie möglich und es sollen alle
impfen die impfen können und dann müssen
wir die organisation an die
begebenheiten anpassen
das kann nicht wahr sein dass wir
ständig hin und her diskutieren müssen
lasst uns anfangen das ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt will wir verlieren
unendlich viel zeit war das luxus
gewesen frau teichert mit astrazeneca
das zunächst in frage zu stellen mit
fehlenden studien für ältere menschen
die schweiz großbritannien haben
trotzdem verimpft waren wir zu
vorsichtig zu ängstlich oder zu
bürokratisch es ist bei uns so geregelt
dass wir uns auf die daten verlassen
ich persönlich bin auch froh dass wir
eine organisation haben nämlich die
stiko die sich genau mit solchen sachen
auseinandersetzt und die das
wissenschaftlich begründet und so ich es
nachvollziehen kann war zum zeitpunkt
der ersten empfehlung waren die daten
noch gar nicht da auf die man sich
stützen konnte
deswegen finde ich es gut dass die stiko
das jetzt auch revidiert hat und gesagt
hat jetzt haben wir die daten jetzt
wissen wir dass es gut funktioniert und
jetzt empfehlen wir es auch für über
65-jährige und ich bin eigentlich froh
dass wir einen solchen prozess in
deutschland haben und man weiß da gucken
fachleute hin da sind wissenschaftler
daran beteiligt und es wird nach
studiendaten ausgewertet weil sonst
könnte es tatsächlich passieren dass man
im eifer des gefechtes vielleicht auch
wichtige sachen übersieht frau mag sie
haben das recht gewandt
60 sekunden bitte noch wir sind gleich
am ende der sendung
stellen sie sich einmal vor es mir
tatsächlich aus gekommen dass nur der
probanden in der studie über 65 gewesen
wären wir hätten einen schönster gehabt
und es wäre fürchterlich gewesen also
noch mal ich finde das was wir gerade
die krise bewältigen es geht um den
minister zu zitieren wir haben sicher
das eine oder andere war es nicht gut
läuft ich meine aber jetzt im moment mit
belohnungen die ich für richtig und
vertretbar halte mit dem mit dem impfen
das ist auf die hausärzte auf die
betriebsärzte ausgegeben im april wenn
wir genügend impfstoff haben mit den
testungen sowohl den schnelltest als
auch den eigenes sind wir jetzt wirklich
auf einem guten weg und ich bin immer
noch sehr sehr hoffnungsvoll dass wir im
sommer die 1 200 unser leben zu bekunden
dann bauen wir jetzt hier
das meine ich auch nicht abwertend
sondern in die zukunft auf das prinzip
hoffnung ich bedanke mich bei karin maag
bodenteicher bei martin terhardt und bei
stephan zinner liebe zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde das thema klimawandel
und energiewende können wir auf den
atomstrom verzichten morgens ist es zehn
jahre her dass das japanische
atomkraftwerk fukushima von einer
unglaublichen katastrophe heimgesucht
wurde das ist übrigens auch morgen ein
schwerpunkt im gesamten phoenix programm
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas
bade thema unter anderem wird ihnen
bekannt vorkommen wenn sie der sendung
jetzt gerade beigewohnt haben
impfstrategie der hausärzte bleiben sie
bei uns